hello do you know my boyfriend eric erik
was testing to a girl while we were
broke it up
he was talking bad about me behind my
back did the addict
say something about me i i don't want to
say it because i know it's going to stop
and it did sound really bad it also
involved someone that you probably would
have never
expected then again maybe you would
hey my 90 day fans fam it's melisa here
we couldn't catch a break when it comes
to all the drama on the latest episode
of happily ever after
so i'll make sure to get you updated on
all of that
and just a few but first let's go ahead
and get you caught up on larissa
who is dealing with a worst case
scenario right now
ericky have you been saying to this girl
that i'm a bad
mother that i don't take showers so i
decided to call her
to find out some kind of a truth
okay before we get deeper into this let
me just
refresh your memory larissa's friend
kicked her out of the house because she
decided to get back into a relationship
with eric
and her friend doesn't support it
larissa then reached out to eric to ask
if she can stay with him
and he agreed but now she's finding out
that she
might have moved in with the enemy did
the attic say something about me
because i'm very confused and the end
law
listen i don't know you um
but all i can tell you is that guys the
worst
man and calling him a man is an insult
to real man
we hung out one night and like he not
only
bashed you entirely uh to a complete
stranger who was me at the time
but he also bashed you in front of his
parents
now i know when you hear the word bash
you might think he just said
oh she's crazy or oh she went to jail
no he bashed her on an entirely
different level and her ex-husband
you know who was involved i don't want
to say it because i know it's going to
sound really bad
but i no you can
what he said was stuff like when they
met with colt
that they discussed how you would
like gift calls and how
uh you would give eric
you know what i mean this came out of
left field for me
supposedly during one of eric and
larissa's breakups which there have been
plenty of them
colt decided to invite eric to his house
to
hang out and then larissa said she
forgave eric for doing that because
she thought he had a good heart you
don't do this
right you don't go to my ex you don't
try any kind of situation
you try to destroy me when i ask him
about the meeting with gold
he goes oh you know he told me that
the way that she
and then i told him about the way that
she
then we realized that it was different
like if it was a joke
if what she's saying is true it is
beyond
childish and honestly at this point i'm
a bit confused
because if colt wanted to be done with
larissa
as bad as he said he did i just don't
see why he would want to hang out
with anybody that had anything to do
with her it just doesn't make sense
but it brings me to my next point e.t
recently spoke with colt and miss debbie
and we asked him could he ever see
himself getting back with larissa
his response says a lot well that's a
million dollar question
and honestly i don't know i like i said
i haven't been in a room with her in a
year and a half and
i can't imagine having a conversation
with her without it escalating into some
kind of argument but
i don't know debbie how would you feel
if they ever reunited
that's not for me to say if that's what
he really wanted in life
then i would be behind him again but i
would hope
he makes smarter decisions in the future
he said he doesn't know he didn't say no
well while larissa was struggling
through heartbreak this week
colt was dealing with jess fighting with
his mom
i know definitely called for nothing
you you laundry for coffee no you do my
laundry sometimes yes
listen don't put your hand on my face
don't do that
i'm done
that night colt sent miss debbie home by
herself
and he stayed to party with jess's
family he returned to the hotel
with a hangover the next morning only to
find miss debbie upset
and done with jess co could have brushed
his hair
that's all i'm saying i'm a little tired
right now
okay our next and final highlight goes
to elizabeth
who's reconsidering that second wedding
in moldova
do you want him to see him watch the
baby or do you want him to go get a job
i want him to get a job
we agreed upon this i don't know why
you're saying this
well yeah we agreed upon it but like i
can change my mind if i want to change
my mind
why are you getting married the second
time
if you i'm totally fine not getting
married a second time how about that
what what yes i'm with you chuck on that
one
well next week on happily ever after
larissa confronts eric
about those horrible things he allegedly
said about her
you hate me you hate me everybody hates
you don't they
you know you bashing me you talk about
my teammates you too strange about it
where you at right now larissa you have
to look for that love that you're
seeking
within yourself girl i know it sounds
cheesy
but it's so true alright 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual
we are covering it all see you next time
you